I'm not ashamed because I'm white if
every Caucasian is a bigot I guess every
muslim's a terrorist every liberal is
right so with regards to every Caucasian
being a bigot and his claim that then
therefore every Muslim is a terrorist
and every liberal is Right which is you
know definitely not correct especially
if you're talking about the progressive
mob there there's a variety of
fundamental problems with the woke
reductive algorithm or ideology that Ben
and Tom are criticizing we did research
back in 2016 looking at politically
correct author authoritarianism and and
that was back when psychologists were
just starting to analyze left-wing
authoritarianism and we found that the
best predictors of being a left-wing
authoritarian were being not verbally
intelligent that was a walloping
predictor it was the variable most most
closely associated with intelligence
that I had ever seen including grades if
you're not very bright the woke ideology
is very attractive to you